hey guys ryan the right here hi lauren
the gaw here
what would a garby i have no idea i
imagine it's like some type of dentistry
thing
okay
like something with gums
okay
yeah
anyway we're gonna watch the trailer
today for left behind
what's that um it's a nicholas cage
movie i love nicholas cage there's a
time where you would say nicholas cage
movie people would be like oh i was
gonna be pretty good i think that he's
fantastic he's he's an interesting guy
he's really changed over the years he's
one of those actors who will like do a
[ __ ] ton of shitty movies and then come
out with a movie and be like oh wow you
can still actually why not he's nicholas
case he can do whatever he wants if he
wants to do a silly movie about some kid
sorcerer then you do that nicholas cage
he's always entertaining to watch yes he
is even if the movie sucks he's always
entertaining i mean even uh what's that
movie called with cher moonstruck i
think that was his first movie maybe
even
and he he has a hook for a hand and he
like goes crazy in one of the scenes
it's just great well that was great
nicholas cage days now it's like
nicholas cage has sort of become a
parody of himself but this movie a lot
of people have been saying the trailer
is pretty good for it
i think it deals with like revelations
ah yeah all right which if you guys
don't know is a part of christianity
christian denomination about the end of
the world and how we're all gonna get
punished
because we are horrible sinners
and some will go to heaven some will go
to hell there's gonna be like a seven
year war
some [ __ ] like that anyway yeah conform
to jesus because a lot of great things
where else you'll go to house will go to
hell yeah that's that's what
christianity is what christianity's
telling you
let's watch this i wonder how many
people we just defended
hi mom chloe welcome home
so is everything set for dad's surprise
party
uh he got called into uh
can i buy you a coffee i'm waiting for
someone
my dad hi sweetheart hey
welcome aboard panco flight 257 to
london my time today will be six hours
and 30 minutes i love you
there's a lot of diversity on that
airplane
oh no
people from all over this plane and
simply vanished
i know you all want answers and believe
me so do i and i'll do my best to get
them
i heard some doctors talking it's not
just here it's all for the world one of
these days
chloe are you okay yeah but mom and remy
they're both
gone irene knew this was coming the way
it happened how could she know that
he took them to protect them from the
darkest time in the history of this
world
the god that my mother talked about
would never do something like this
we all have a right to know we're going
to die
i have no spoilers no flaps no elevators
and if i run this thing dry no reverse
thrust i need some room
i just really need you to know how much
i love you no matter what happens
looks like the end of the world
wasn't there a mini series or something
like that i i i believe there was
already a movie about it like years ago
i mean there's always something about no
i think it was left behind oh really
yeah i have no idea i mean it looks
interesting
i mean can i just say that the whole
point of that like everybody was
freaking out they're like who do i need
to know who's gonna die well the point
was that you guys were left behind and
that means that everybody else that
wasn't left behind was already saved and
you guys are gonna die yeah that's what
that means dumb [ __ ] you're gonna die
you should have prayed to jesus yeah
anyway
looks interesting looks interesting
i don't know it's like part action movie
but then like part religious movie and
like
nicholas cage
and then the girl is running and then
nicholas cage used to land the plane
and i don't know the wife knew that that
was gonna happen and
well like the concept in itself is
interesting i know it's based on a book
and everything
but it's like
focusing on like these people on a plane
i guess is dangerous and stuff but it
doesn't appeal to me all that much it
just seems people on the plane yeah like
something about it is like what about
all the people that were on earth no no
like that's interesting too but it seems
like most of the focus is going to be
about these people on a plane well
that's where nicholas cage is i guess
yeah and nicholas cage looks like he's
doing a good job again didn't you know
like he's crying i still love nicolas
cage so stop it but who's that actress
at the beginning of the trailer who
plays the mom i know who it is but i
can't think of her name is that caroline
and the city chick yes but i don't know
what the actress's name is right when
she's like you're home i just that kind
of pulled me out of the trailer right
away oh really the moment that pulled me
out of the trailer was the woman in the
hospital that said it's happening all
over the world do you really believe
that i just feel like you got such a
awesome concept like revelations is
actually a pretty cool concept to
explore what their characters are
focusing on the characters don't seem
that interesting to me that's my one
problem characters are human well yeah
focusing on human things no totally
that's why they weren't saved i know
but still it's like i mean it looks like
a pg-13 version of a movie that could be
really dark and heavy i just feel like
the movie is really dark and heavy would
that turn people off it's [ __ ] the
end of the world though it's gonna be
dark and heavy when it happens like i'm
gonna see it it looks interesting enough
to check it out but if for some reason
i'm not entirely confident in its
execution even though it's just a
trailer but i'm not well it's also it's
true it is a very very heavy topic and
if done well i feel like the movie could
be successful but if it's not done well
then
they just lost it i just don't want them
to hold back like this is something
where you could really go balls out
and i wish i hope it does that what was
this
balls out i don't know i rolled my eyes
you'll see it in the video how is that
balls out i don't know it doesn't make
any sense like falls out yeah like my
balls don't flick out like that i don't
know you do things all the time where
i'm like i have no idea what he's doing
yeah well no thanks for recommending
that trailer it does look interesting
enough you know what's going to happen
right now right
and anyone who is really excited to see
this even though i've said it's
interesting and i'm going to they're
going to hate us they're going to
[ __ ] hate us right just because we're
not just as excited about it but if
you're uh new to the channel and if you
don't hate us you can subscribe and
lauren has her own channel too you can
subscribe to her channel right there
what yeah yeah and it's great stuff on
her channel man you know like
sometimes
when you can't find the perfect match
it feels like the end of the world and
lauren's here to help you
lauren's here to help you anyway guys
we're gonna do some shout outs yeah i
thought it'd be fun to try something new
and exciting and give some shout outs
yeah
i've never heard of that before so uh
here we go this is fresh uh gamer
bigfoot hey i'm recently new to your
channel welcome you seem pretty cool and
funny thank you oh and he said this to
us also can i get a shout out please
okay and thank you p.s keep doing the
good work will do yeah gamer boog foot
dude thank you for the compliment he
said that to us on our if i stay trailer
reaction oh i was in that one you were
in that one lauren coincidence that
you're here today hello
was it fate
was it written in scripture i think so i
think so yeah i know uh dude compliments
like that are awesome because my ego is
already pretty big
and oh god the fact that like you added
to my ego it's like i'm gonna be
non-stop now thanks
thanks a lot i'm confident i'm
enthusiastic
i'm charming as hell lauren tell him
about charming man he's not i'm pretty
charming she's lying
she's laughing lauren does she lies
i would never lie but gamer bigfoot dude
you say gaming you keep those big feet
up you know what they say with people
with big feet they actually scientists
say that's not true
what scientist
i don't know i'm a scientist did someone
just tell you scientists saying then you
took their word for it no i like read
something online or they said that
there's no correlation between penis
size and foot or hand size
yeah my cock's way bigger than my feet
robert
robert kerr hey ryan can i get a shout
out i'm new to the channel please please
please he saw he said on the five stage
show the reaction as well why do people
say plus i i don't know is it really
that much harder to like write out the
word please
it's like the extra seconds are precious
though i don't know i'm a really fast
typer
like i could write just the word please
and then i would have written out please
instead of plus
now you just
look stupid robert um lauren wants you
to fix your typing skills okay if you're
going to be new to this channel you've
got to know how to write properly my
friend yes please it's part of the
qualification of being a subscriber you
think you just hit that button and you
can check out our videos no no we'll
i'll [ __ ] block you if you're not
right it's like hazing oh yeah man like
grammar hazing have you ever seen a
hazing
no oh
i thought we would have had a cool story
here i mean i've heard about hazing i
wasn't a sorority so where is this
sorority crazy was there like a lot of
partying all the time i don't wouldn't
say it was crazy but there were parties
were there drug addicts maybe not that i
know of but probably college you know
we're in front of the camera just make
up some [ __ ] to make it i was being
honest
yeah everybody was doing blow
there you go we're trying to increase
views here hello jesus christ yeah
because you talking like that is gonna
increase views yeah youtubers don't make
money those ads are nothing
those ads are nothing click on all the
ads guys can you click on all the ads
guys please please it doesn't benefit us
please just just do it just do it close
close stitch plus click on the ads why
are we talking about lilo and stitch
could use blue blue i'm saying the way
that robert kerr
spelled the word it's plus but you're
going blue no i think plus you don't
hear it no it's going deep into your
atom's apple plus i don't have an adam's
apple well it's going deep into your
your throat okay
captain fury
captain fury
yo ryan can i get a shout out please yes
yo yo yo
yeah captain fury you can totally have a
shout out captain fury what are you
captain of
oh you know what you were wrong that
actually wasn't captain furry
furry captain fur are you very hairy oh
wait somebody tweeted me and they're
like lauren how do i get a girl i heard
that girls don't like guys that are
hairy is that true it all depends on the
girl i mean it depends on the girl but i
just responded hashtag manscaping like
you don't like facial hair uh like this
would be a lot right no i don't like
facial hair yeah like some girls like
facial yeah some girls really like it
yeah and uh it all depends my friend but
captain furry if you are furry embrace
it hashtag manscaping
but if you want to keep the bush keep
the bush let it grow let it flourish let
it go everyone says you're supposed to
trim it because it makes your penis look
bigger
does it now have you not heard that
that's what all guys say um i just trim
it to
i just think it looks better hardest
part to trim the testicles
all you subscriber males out there know
what i'm talking about if you've
attempted it
hardest part especially when you've like
already came and then like your balls
are dropped a little bit it's like you
it's better to do it before you come
that way your balls are more tight
and it's just easier that way and you
got to get a good razor fun fact fun
fact
captain furry probably knows a lot about
that a lot of people don't realize we do
multiple videos at a time we're wearing
the same clothes guys how stupid are you
what do you think like i just wear the
same thing here like four times in a row
that's what some people think is that
they're like why is he wearing the same
shirt again
ryan only owns one shirt but lauren owns
a lot of different clothes so no i don't
wear the same thing here multiple times
no i have about seven shirts and i
alternate between all of them and like
two people really sound for you well
we're supposed to go shopping when i
have money yeah but you don't have money
so cool later youtube doesn't pay
anything i just do this as a hobby click
on the ads please click on the ads it
will not benefit us it will not benefit
us